real quick go check out jayatal the uk's
most exciting electronic music duo their
newest release connected is available
wherever you get music it's energetic
melodic blast of electronica ingeniously
infused with acoustic instruments and
they support the david pakman show check
them out using the link below
let's start today with an update on the
russian invasion of ukraine because yeah
there's been less media coverage of this
but that doesn't mean there aren't
newsworthy things happening and it is
going so poorly according to new reports
for russia
that there are renewed questions as to
whether putin is quote doomed which we
will get to in a moment reuters and
others but we'll look at a reuters
report reporting that russian troops are
fleeing and getting back over the border
into russia
russia has largely ceded its gains near
kharkiv rights reuters and many of the
withdrawing russian soldiers have exited
ukraine moving over the border back into
russia this is for a senior u.s military
official
as it pulls back the u.s has seen
anecdotal reports of russian forces
abandoning equipment
again disorganized command and control
is mentioned that's been
uh that's been a hallmark a staple of
russian activity so far
the remarks to pentagon reporters
followed a weekend of rapid gains for
ukrainian forces ukraine's general staff
said its soldiers had recaptured more
than 20 towns and villages in just the
last day
as ukrainian forces swept deeper into
territory seized from fleeing russian
troops now the the big stories here
were of course a war of aggression by
russia that's an accurate and true story
expectations early that this would be a
very easy military win for russia
very quickly that assumption evaporated
however
there was the belief that although on
the one hand the longer it went the
worse it is for russia
that eventually if russia decided to
commit the resources
it would overwhelm ukrainian troops
that's not happening and in fact things
are going in the opposite direction the
u.s military official reads the same
article was upbeat but cautious when
describing the russian advances it's
clear they're fighting hard
uh ukraine said it repelled attempted
russian advances in two important areas
of the donetsk region
the city of bakmut and mayorsk near the
coal producing town of horlivka the
general staff said in an evening update
but the senior u.s official said russia
was still focusing its firepower on
bakmoot so a lot more tactical
information that you can read if that is
interesting to you
now the question becomes what about the
propaganda war and what about the future
of vladimir putin there's an interesting
article in uh the hill which is worth
reading if not
uh it's worth reading let's just put it
that way
and it's it's by alexander motil who's
an opinion contributor and it says like
his soldiers is putin doomed now the
article is somewhat hyperbolic
admittedly and the article writes
vladimir putin is kaput
the proof of that is the below letter
written by a 26 year old soldier in the
russian army vivi tarasenko we know
nothing about tarasenko except he was a
resident of putin's brainchild the
so-called luhansk people's republic and
that he has a wife valeria and a small
son we also know tarasenko died in
battle during the recent ukrainian
offensive in the kharkiv province
ukrainian intel found the letter
um
the letter was written with little
punctuation and no capital letters so
the letter reads
this letter is for the future if i
should die or be taken prisoner or
become a vegetable
written july 17th 2022 it's very hard to
write i'm crying but i must beloved lara
tell our son what kind of dad i was that
we were sent as cannon fodder to zaliman
a village in kharkiv province without
armor without ammunition without normal
weapons this is about our situation when
our son grows up tell him his dad wanted
very much to return home to be the best
dad ever i've been drinking and i'm
writing emotionally i know that this all
will be forgotten and that you will be
living your own life that you'll find a
new husband that'll simply disappear in
the war like all the guys
unfortunately i didn't have a normal
life say that dad was an athlete didn't
smoke didn't drink it's terrible that
everyone has forgotten me it's very hard
to accept all this but all people die
and this cycle can't be changed it's bad
to die in the summer if only i were at
the seashore
and
what is written in this hill article is
that tarasenko's complaints are not
unique
the russian leadership with putin at the
head has evinced a profoundly cavalier
attitude towards lives not just of
innocent ukrainians but also of russian
soldiers and what this article and
others go on to say
is that there is really no path out of
this for putin
that is going to be anything short
of a of a failure and doom for putin now
early there were all of these
speculations is putin's sick and has a
death wish and is determined to be
assassinated eventually by uh operatives
from other countries or is putin
so drunk on the idea of reassembling
some version of the ussr that he's not
thinking clearly and
whatever the case may be
i at this point think the ship has sort
of sailed on making rational sense out
of what putin was thinking and when he
was thinking it and what the end goal is
here
but it is clear that if there is going
to be a win for russia
it's going to be a win only with
completely revised objectives and so at
this point
when this didn't
end in two weeks
we started talking about well it's
likely going to be more than months at
this point and what is the ultimate goal
because a complete and total takeover
over takeover of ukraine seems
increasingly unlikely
it seems quite plausible that putin and
his cronies will revise their military
objectives and they will revise them to
say our goal is actually to control a
lot less territory than we initially
planned
with those revised objectives they may
be able to come away with something that
they would call a win for propaganda
purposes but there's also a fear
the fear is
that as russia and putin realize
we're not going to be able to continue
mounting offensives and really take
ukraine in the way that originally some
projected us to do
there's the fear
that an increasingly belligerent putin
will resort to those tactical nuclear
weapons these are sometimes called
battlefield nuclear weapons it's not
like the massive bomb that destroys
entire cities
uh but they are battlefield or tactical
nukes
and that that would be something that
putin is willing to do
to kind of maintain this image of
strength the kind of hair brained
uh caricature
of the alpha male that has pervaded the
mega movement in the united states quite
frankly it's sort of a similar dynamic
that is a fear that an increasingly
cornered putin would go in that
direction so it is unpredictable what is
going to happen but what we know is that
it is not going well for russian troops
and there is still an invasion there is
still a war even if more and more
mainstream corporate media isn't talking
about it
if you want to see one statistic
that really exposes
the united states
as a growing
dystopian hellscape
of
anti-intellectualism and non-thinking
it is this statistic
in the last three polls
herschel walker is leading rafael
warnock
now if you're wondering who these people
are i will remind you herschel walker is
the republican senate nominee in georgia
right now that seat is held by raphael
warnock raphael warnock is an
intelligent
thinking
uh nuanced elected official who whether
you agree with him or not on any
individual policy
clearly has the interests of george's
residence
as his priority
and can engage with others
in clear
and productive ways where you understand
what he thinks and you can talk
substantively about issues herschel
walker is a former football player who
can barely speak coherently
can't explain his views about any issue
and is
epitomizing
the worst of the non-thinking maga
movement
and yes in recent polls
walker has taken a lead if we look at
the last three polls in that race
the insider advantage poll has walker
plus three
the emerson pole has walker plus two
and the trafalgar pole has walker plus
one those are the last three polls we
have two of them from august and one
from september
this is a man who cannot express himself
this is a man who cannot
explain
why he believes what he believes on any
issue
and there are enough people in georgia
seemingly willing to vote for him that
he might actually take out incumbent
senator raphael warnock many of you have
written to me and you've said david you
know it was bad when bush beat gore and
it was bad when trump beat hillary and
it was bad when the country elected
marjorie taylor green and on and on but
there is something i can't put my finger
on if the country elects walker over
warnock i'm getting the hell out of here
and i don't know that people are
literally meaning that often when people
say i'll move to canada they don't
really mean it it's also really
difficult to move to canada just as a
reminder
this is what we're talking about when we
talk about herschel walker here is
walker asked why he hasn't agreed to
debate warnock
it's a very strange answer
senator raphael warnock wants to debate
you you didn't debate during the
primaries where you walked away with 68
of the republican votes
why won't you commit to a debate well
first of all senator warnock has nothing
else to talk about he don't want to talk
about the high gas prices he don't want
to talk about the high groceries i've
told him many times i'm ready to debate
him anytime any day i just want to make
it for the fans not about a political
party or about some media and all these
for the fans these are elected officials
or want to be elected officials
wow
here is the same herschel walker asked
by cnn reporter manu raju should there
be new laws in the wake of the latest
shooting
hey roger with cnn i am good guys are
you do you support any new gun laws in
the wake of this texas shooting
do you support the new gun laws in the
wake up
i like to see it and everything and
stuff and then famous famously herschel
walker weighing in on his plan for
uh
dealing with shootings through social
media see that is the person willing
that weapon you know kanekia able you
know and uh you know that's the problem
that we have and i said what we need to
do is look into how we can stop those
things you know he talked about doing a
disinformation what about getting a
department that can look at young men
that's looking at uh women that looking
at uh just social media what about doing
that we need a department looking at
young men that's looking at women that's
looking at social media he is now
leading in the three recent polls
this
is scary as hell
scary as hell
let me know what you think will
ultimately happen in that race monday 9
19 is our next one day membership drive
if you've been thinking about getting a
membership but you'd like to get a
massive humiliatingly huge discount
humiliating to me let's be honest i'll
get on my newsletter at davidpakman.com
monday morning you'll get an email
telling you exactly how to take
advantage of this great discount 919 is
the day
one of our sponsors today is jayatal
jayatal is a stellar melodic dance music
duo in one of the uk's most exciting
electronic acts jaetal have made their
name through legendary live shows that
incorporate drums guitar electronics
taking them on tours across europe
they've appeared on bbc their newest
release called connected will knock you
off your feet written and recorded
entirely remotely during covid my
favorite track from the album is the one
you're hearing right now called it's
coming round again
[Music]
probably because i'm a drummer but i
love acoustic drums accompanied by a bed
of electronic layers and the track
really gets the drums going in all of
their music even something as simple as
the synth bass sounds like it was
carefully adjusted for hours to hit your
ear just the right way these guys will
take you on a journey and jaital are big
fans of the david pakman show if you
like unusual but deeply gratifying
electronica check out jayatal on their
new release connected wherever you
stream or buy music they're on youtube
and social media you can book them for a
show and you can find them using the
link below
for the second day in a row i have a
really good example for you of when an
interviewer
realizes their guest isn't answering the
question
and keeps asking the same question and
it makes the guest look really dumb
when they don't answer the question in
this case we're talking about jared
kushner jared kushner is donald trump's
son-in-law and jared kushner was asked
here
by a k burley from sky news why did
donald trump have those documents at his
house
why did donald trump have those
documents at his house
why did trump have the documents at his
house and much like yesterday's example
where former democratic senator al
franken kept asking alice stewart a
republican
strategist
when was a supreme court nomination just
not even
acted on because it was the last year
before an election when when when when
when
um jared kushner doesn't answer the
question and so we're going to take a
look at this and of course jared kushner
just wants to talk about his book
and in doing so he says a lot of things
that don't make any sense as it's very
common with these folks let's take a
listen to this piece shattered there
very tranquil post for the family a
piece shattered by an fbi rage why did
the president take home toxic top secret
documents
uh you have to ask him uh that question
but you know what i will say is if if
you look at my book you'll see that he
was under a constant attack
but he took top secret documents home
potentially risking the security of the
united states yeah i think that it's
something that again this seems like
it's an issue of paperwork that should
have been
by the way
that's a new talking point that they've
settled on first it was the documents
were planted
then it was i declassified them then it
was i gave them back when they asked me
but i didn't and there were empty
folders
now it's listen
whatever it is that took place with the
documents
it's a paperwork issue and this is a way
to not have to account for by i mean
they already told the lies so it's a
little late
but the idea of it's a paperwork issue
understand the motivations of that it's
basically saying no matter what
documents there were
no matter where they were
no matter who moved them no matter what
their classification status was it's a
minor issue that's what it means to say
it's a paperwork issue and k burley
doesn't let kushner get away with it to
be worked out between doj and him i
don't know what he took or what he
didn't take but i think right now we're
relying on leaks to the media which is
the same thing we've seen the photograph
haven't we where it says top secret
yeah but that could have been fake too
guys that could have been staged yeah
like i said i i i i've seen a lot of
allegations made by the media over my
four years that turned out not to be
true so i think that this whole thing is
actually elevated so the fact that we've
seen photographs that say top secret
document we should wait and see whether
or not they were even though we're being
told by the fbi
uh that they were
the look on kushner's space right now
basically says it all so
the pictures released by the fbi
of top secret documents with the fbi
confirming that they're top secret
documents we need what exactly who's
going to tell us right if they are not
the authority on what the search warrant
turned up who's going to tell us yeah
like i said i go into my book the
accusations that were made of trump uh i
just if you could answer that question
yeah i mean first of all he was the
president united states he had the
highest clearance in the world so i
don't know if like this may be a
paperwork issue this may be i i don't
know like i said i haven't been involved
in the details of it he just has no idea
at the end of the day he has no clue and
again he floats paperwork issue and
again understand that every every single
one of these lines
could really be analyzed and looked at
at a deeper level kushner there when he
mentioned it's like they can't go three
words without some kind of liar
distortion when kushner says
he was the president he had the highest
level of clearance in the world
that's not relevant
to the legality of taking boxes of
documents to his house and as we already
know because it's been explored in
detail
the classification status of the
documents was also not the issue when it
comes to many of the criminal statutes
which donald trump may have violated so
every little detail here every detail is
a distortion
or a misunderstanding or a lie and what
i like about this strategy al franken
did it yesterday
give me an example of when this was done
to another supreme court justice
well listen i mean it's just it's
precedent but if it's precedent tell me
when was it done and alice stewart
couldn't do it if you don't know the
clip i'm referring to it's on the
youtube channel you can find it from
yesterday um same thing here
why did he have the documents why did he
have the argument are you saying they
weren't actually what the picture shows
they were
and they crumble they crumble because
they don't have a defense now
is it believable that kushner simply
hasn't talked to trump about this
despite the fact that we know he's hung
out with trump a bunch of times since
the search warrant was executed it's
really not believable but he would have
been better off focusing on that from a
pr perspective if i were advising him
instead of saying well he has whatever
access he wants because he was the
president or it's a paperwork issue
which minimizes the fact that we're
talking about possible crimes i would
have just stuck to i really can't speak
to this i just it's it's not about me i
can't speak to this i don't know
anything about i would have just stuck
with that in that alone hey this is
really funny
sean hannity last night on his fox news
propaganda program
scrolled a list of trump's crimes and
misdeeds on the screen
thinking that it's a great defense of
trump thinking it's some kind of a
exculpation of trump's misdeeds
and it makes trump look guiltier than
ever you you just have to see this video
sean hannity is a big trump propagandist
and even though as january sixth riots
were unfolding we know now hannity was
texting and saying he's got this we've
got to stop this he's got to go out and
put a stop to this this is really really
bad
he has become a default apologist for
everything that donald trump has done
and one of the stories that sean hannity
loves to tell is that all these
investigations of trump were very much
unfair and he quite literally scrolls
the investigations on the screen last
night and it actually reminded me that
trump has been involved in way more
wrongdoing than i even had present in my
mind because there's been so much of it
take a look at this this is just
unbelievable there's witch hunt the
emoluments clause investigation from the
house oversight committee a house ways
and means investigation into trump's
taxes another house investigation into
trump's hotel lease another house
investigation into foreign gift
disclosures a d.c probe in the trump's
inauguration fundraising another similar
investigation from the southern district
of new york and the eastern district of
new york and from new jersey's attorney
general one impeachment investigation
into a regular phone call with ukraine a
second impeachment investigation by the
way just one little detail i hate to
interrupt this i like how hannity calls
it a regular phone call with ukraine
trump calls it a perfect phone call
that would have been a bit too much even
for hannity that would have made hannity
blush so hannity goes with a regular
phone call
um while watching this i found myself
thinking like as as the scroll went up
and down the screen as you can see here
i find myself like oh oh yeah oh that's
right that other oh i completely forgot
about this one that on that one he's
obviously guilty on that one hannity
thinks this is some kind of defense of
trump
and
what is basically being said when
hannity scrolls this indignantly is
why can't they just let him do whatever
the hell he wants to do
whether it's criminal whether it's moral
whether it's ethical let him do it in
peace anything short of that is a
complete and total witch hunt and it's
quite frankly convenient for hannity to
put all of this stuff in one place for
us this is not the defense of trump that
i think sean hannity wanted it to be and
it's a really useful
uh clearinghouse for us to remember all
of the incredible things that he has
done
for frame of reference
one of these things
if it were obama
would have been an incredible scandal on
fox news that they would not have let
obama live down obama
exactly uh and of course there's dozens
and dozens of these if you want to if
you're just listening today
and you want to see this incredible
scroll of trump's misdeeds from fox
we'll have the clip up on our instagram
which you can find at david pakman show
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpakman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
it's great to welcome back to the
program today tom hartman tom hosts the
thom hartmann program and is also author
of the hidden history series the latest
book in that series is the hidden
history of neoliberalism how reaganism
gutted america and how to restore its
greatness tom always great having you on
thank you david thanks for inviting me
so um one of the interesting things
about reaganism is i don't think this is
the first time that we can say this but
there were sort of certain stories that
started to be told which shifted the way
that in large part uh corporate and
political media talked about politics uh
we know about the welfare queen stories
we we know about a lot of these
different stories that's overtly or
sometimes not so overtly were used to
shift our focus about how we should
think about politics welfare programs
etc can you talk a little bit about the
the circumstances in which this shift
from keynesianism to neoliberalism took
place and if you want to also define
neo-liberalism as you use the term in
the book that would be great too sure
yeah neoliberalism was a political and
economic philosophy that was originated
in europe in the nineteen forties in an
effort to come up with a system a
political system that governments could
use that would prevent them from ever
becoming fascist or communist this was
in the wake of you know world war ii
and uh
you know sadly
neoliberalism every time it's been
applied it's been applied to a country
um one of two things has happened you
know
first of all it always flips the country
into oligarchy which is a very unstable
political system you and i talked about
when my book on oligarchy came out
rarely last more than a generation or
two it's so unstable and oligarchy
typically either flips into fascism uh
as it has in russia as it did in iraq
and and over the short term well over
the short term actually what happened in
chile was the on the other alternative
which is that it flips
oligarchy flips into democracy which is
what happened when they overthrow
overthrew pinochet
so the united states now is still in
this neoliberal phase this 40-year
neoliberal experiment and we've got
enormous pressures coming out of the
republican party to turn america into a
fascist state and enormous pressure from
the democratic party to turn america
into a democratic state small d
and
uh or you could say a democratic
republic
um the definition of neoliberalism is
pretty straightforward these guys
believed that because there's billions
of decisions being made in the
marketplace every second i mean right
now there's probably a thousand people
in this literally as we're speaking
choosing which brand of orange juice to
buy um you know there's just billions of
decisions being made in the marketplace
and that they saw as a huge collective
wisdom and therefore they said the
marketplace should be defining the rules
of the marketplace and and also the
rules of governance which traditionally
define the rules of the marketplace now
this in and of itself is an insane idea
it's like saying you know if
i mean the marketplace is nothing more
than a game that we play that involves
money just like football is a game that
we play that involves this ball made out
of pigskin and you know this is like
saying well what the nfl should do is
whichever team has the most money should
just let them write the rules and decide
how many men they can have on the field
during the game and how many their
competitors must have because they're in
charge now basically neoliberalism
always leads to the rise of billionaire
oligarchs and the massive consolidation
of huge corporations at the expense of
small communities in small businesses so
number one low taxes cut because because
the billionaires and the big
corporations are the major players in
the economy they need to be encouraged
because they're the darwinian winners so
that's why we have a three percent
income tax rate right now for
billionaires and 30 for you and me um uh
number number ten and we've got two two
men now who control more than half a
half ha have more wealth in the bottom
half of america number two uh so-called
free trade corporations should be free
to go anywhere in the world and find the
cheapest labor possible because nations
don't matter to hell with nations
although a nation should keep people
within their borders
they shouldn't keep corporations within
their borders
and uh you know there's a bunch of
corollaries to that um you know that uh
you know kind of derive out of those
basic oh and and that labor is always an
interference in the marketplace any
labor d you know if labor has power that
distorts the marketplace because labor
isn't the major player labor is just
subordinate to management and therefore
all me labor unions should be destroyed
so reagan adopted this and applied it to
the united states threw us into
neoliberalism took us out of classic
adam smith economics what's sometimes
referred to as keynesian economics
because john maynard keynes had
fine-tuned it but really it's what uh
particularly in his book a theory of
moral sentiments in 1784 that adam smith
described in some detail
before uh let let me pause there so
before we move on into more of the
history now that you've kind of defined
it for us um there are some in my
audience who are
uh
further to to the left than i am
certainly and and are truly sort of bona
fide socialists and i don't use that
term pejoratively who sometimes will
write to me and they'll say you know
david there's really not that much
breathing room between
neo-liberalism as you've just defined it
and written about and northern european
social democracy it's all way too far to
the right for them can you weigh in a
little bit on
is there really substantive difference
between what you just defined and
northern european social democracy or
are they more similar maybe than some of
us like to acknowledge
well first of all if you compare you
know pinochet's chile or russia
uh or iraq where where nouriel mellicky
has turned himself into basically you
know
a dictator
um yeah there's some significant
differences between those countries in
any country in europe that said uh
margaret thatcher was the f you know i
mean neoliberalism was invented in the
40s these guys pitched it aggressively
through the 50s and 60s and largely were
considered crackpots
and then we got the inflation of the
seventies as a result the arab oil
embargo in 73 in the fall of the shaw in
79 and that inflation uh was the perfect
uh tool or uh
opportunity that milton friedman used
here in the united states to pitch
neoliberalism not just here but all
around the world he said neoliberalism
will fix inflation which hadn't even
been part of the original sales pitch
but hey you know take opera this is
naomi klein shock doctrine right you got
a problem we got a solution
and so uh margaret thatcher was actually
the first to buy it
and you know broke the coal union which
was the strongest union in in all of the
united kingdom nobody thought it was
even possible in our first months in
office and and and uh and then you know
privatized the railroad and did a whole
bunch of other neoliberal reforms so the
uk uh is not that far behind the united
states in terms of neoliberalism we're
we're only farther ahead because we were
more neoliberal to begin with we didn't
have a national health service we didn't
have free college um you know we didn't
have the basic stuff that england has a
strong a strong really strong welfare
state
so you know yeah neoliberalism has
infected europe and
some so-called neoliberal reforms most
of them being pushed by the imf by the
way
and being trumpeted at davos every year
by all the billionaires who show up
have crept into uh many of the european
countries in particular france
um and and the united kingdom as i just
mentioned
but
uh and and and you know there's even a
debate about neoliberalism in sweden
right now
but um but to say that it's the same
thing no that's that's uh just
not right you know one of the
interesting things about
uh the replacement of keynesianism by
neoliberalism relates to this idea that
keynes had in the 30s and if you've read
anything about leisure economics or this
this always comes up keynes had this
idea that soon we would all be working
only 15 hours a week and people would
have all of this leisure time because of
technology and productivity etcetera
etcetera and of course we know it didn't
happen we know that actually the work
week continue to get longer and longer
would canes maybe have been right were
it not for neo-liberalism because it's
so it's so discussed
that was keynes's prediction we know it
didn't happen there's 50 different
explanations as to why is neoliberalism
a part of that
uh to an extent yeah i mean you know
look at france when when they adopted
fully adopted essentially what you're
calling keynesianism after world war ii
um you know
they they were able to get legally get
down to a maximum 30 hour or maybe it
was 32 hour work week as you'll recall i
mean that was a big deal
italy adopted that although they didn't
make it law um it's it was widespread
across europe um you know
four day weeks or shorter work days or
longer lunches
um these are these are not uncommon
although the last decade has seen a
rollback of a lot of that as as
neoliberalism has been pushing hard on
europe and i'm hopeful that this book
you know
several of my books have been translated
into uh i mean last hours of ancient
sunlight into 17 languages i'm hopeful
that this book can get an audience in
europe as well because you know
neoliberalism is knocking on their door
pretty aggressively right now what's the
path to reversing this in the united
states is it as simple as electing
certain candidates
based on their pursuit of particular
policies or is it is it really bigger
than that
no that's that that's it david it's it
you know we need to re-empower labor
elizabeth warren has legislation right
now to do this the national right to
unionize act um you know basically
undoing taft-hartley and and and a whole
series of neoliberal supreme court
decisions
uh number one we need to raise taxes on
the rich on the morbidly rich um the you
know that like i said before the average
billionaire in america is paying three
three percent income tax that that's
wrong and that's why you've got you know
three men ordering more wealth in the
bottom half of america and that wealth
by the way is generally not engaged
productively in the economy they're not
spending it you know i had a a
billionaire on my show and he said you
know i'd i buy i probably own the same
number ju blue jeans as you do i mean
you know i'm i'm without a hundred
thousand times richer than you but i'm
not gonna buy 50 pairs of blue jeans and
uh you know so i'm not helping the
economy anymore you know so that money
really should be in the economy more
broadly
um so we need to go back to tax rates
that are above 50 percent for people
making more than three or three million
dollars a year is where you know uh
basically fdr had it in today's dollars
and and we need to undo so-called free
trade we need to stop corporations from
the arbitrage of trade of labor they we
need to save labor you know the products
sold in the united states should be made
in the united states there's a variety
of ways to do that that were laid out by
alexander hamilton in 1793
the congress adopted and that were u s
policy we had an industrial policy
literally from the george washington
administration to the ronald reagan
administration and reagan blew all that
up and clinton doubled down on it
uh one of the uh kind of pillars of
support for uh neoliberal policies even
if people don't necessarily know the
term neoliberalism you can talk to them
about policies like lower taxes for
businesses for example and they support
these things a lot of this is based on
fundamental misunderstandings of sort of
like how things work and i'll give one
example of that you often hear repeated
oh we need to lower taxes to encourage
businesses to make investments
well
business
expenses are tax deductible so actually
a higher tax rate is more of an
incentive to reinvest because you are
avoiding a higher tax rate by making
tax-deductible investments in your
business it's just a basic thing about
how taxes work brilliantly pointed out
what what do you make of the fact that
these fundamental realities are turned
completely around to gain support of
these policies is it as simple as
educating people
i think so i i really do i you know and
and uh that's why i wrote the book um
you know i'm hoping it's going to be a
fascinating starting point for a lot of
people's conversations because
neoliberalism has guided america when
ronald reagan came into office 65
percent of america was in the middle
class now it's down to 45 percent and of
that 45 percent it's no longer possible
to stay in the middle class with a
single wage earner in the family um you
know and it's no longer possible to stay
out of debt for for at least half of
that 45 percent they're living on credit
card debt mortgage debt student debt
um you know america has more personal
debt than we've ever had in the history
of the of this country more corporate
debt than we've ever had and obviously
more government debt none of those are
healthy things for an economy all of
those are the direct products of
neoliberalism
what do you see as the role of
technology in what may or may not be a
shift away from neoliberalism kind of in
the context of uh not too long ago i
read neil postman's book technopoly
written in the early 90s where he's not
taking an agnostic view about technology
but he's essentially saying in terms of
how it affects economies culture etc
you're going to get the pros and the
cons and it's really about management
and regulation and not about suppressing
a technology which he argued
is is more or less inevitable how does
modern technology social media etc
impact the culture around our economic
systems and things like the future of
neoliberalism
well
technology itself i mean this this is
not an area where the luddites would
jump in and say hooray this is our cause
technology itself is kind of agnostic
with regard to neoliberalism and vice
versa however social media
had you know i mean more than half of
americans now get their news primarily
from facebook yeah
pretty damn shocking
social media is a relatively cheap place
to to spread a message and
neoliberalism has made a small number of
people and a small number of
corporations
mind-bogglingly rich i mean richer than
the pharaohs richer than any king or
kingdom in the history of the world
the british royal family had you know
being worth 14 billion dollars are
pikers they're a joke compared to some
of the billionaires in the united states
so these guys pouring millions of
dollars into ads and trolls and
professional bloggers as it were on
social media and facebook on twitter on
instagram on i mean you you name it
tiktok
this has been going on for some time and
will continue to go on they may not have
hired these people to say hey you're
going to promote neoliberalism it's it
tends to be more focused you're going to
be the guy who's you know the grover
norquist is going to talk about never
raising taxes on billionaires you're
going to be the guy who talks about how
evil unions are body blah and you're
going to be the guy who talks about how
we've got to have free trade or you know
else the world is going to collapse or
etc etc um so you know to the extent
that technology plays a role in this
it's it's largely limited to the role of
propaganda is neoliberal neoliberalism
self-reinforcing in the sense that
by its very nature
it puts many people in a position
of not being able to take a day off from
work because they can't afford to lose
the wages
their health insurance is at risk in
order to protest the very system that
created those conditions and it that in
that sense it reinforces itself
yeah and not only that it follows on
the
uh the opinions and goals of the early
advocates of neoliberalism particularly
barry goldwater and william f buckley
back in 1951 russell kirk wrote this
book the conservative mind i write about
this my book on oligarchy and he
suggested and uh that you know the the
american middle class was growing too
fast and 51 you know we were our middle
class was larger than any in the world
it was growing really really rapidly it
was still only 20 30 percent of
americans but it was growing it was
growing faster than rich people were
getting rich
and and he wrote that at a certain point
the middle class is going to be large
enough and and people are going to be no
longer afraid of poverty enough
that you're going to see three
consequences young people are going to
start to find their elders which will
produce social chaos women are are going
to forget that their their primary
places in the in the kitchen in the
bedroom which is going to create social
chaos and minorities are going to forget
that they have a place in society at the
bottom they're supposed to be the maids
and the janitors and that's going to
cause social chaos when when they start
demanding you know access to the
boardroom and media and things
he didn't explicitly lay it out quite
like that many of his followers did but
he he established the frame in that book
and you know at the time in 61 in 51
when he proposed this everybody thought
he was a crackpot except for buckley and
goldwater
but by the time you know 1967 rolled
around and you know young people like me
at that time were burning our draft
cards women were burning their bras and
this went uh you know doubled down in 72
when the supreme court legalized birth
control in 73 when that legalized
abortion women demanding access to the
workplace and of course the civil rights
movement was really you know roaring in
the 60s and 70s
and at that point republicans started
looking around going holy crap russell
kirk was right and so part of reagan's
mandate when he came into office when
the middle class was 65 percent of
america and was defying the powers to
openly define the power structures of
this country was to cut the middle class
down to size and neoliberalism was the
perfect tool to do that and that's
exactly what happened as i mentioned you
know our middle class is no longer the
middle it's you know it's it's no longer
65 percent of americans 45 percent of
america and it's in debt as it is so
those students have shut up because
they're in debt the the women are you
know right now in a pitched battle
you know over abortion specifically but
over women's rights more generally and
the civil rights movement rolls on too
and and we're seeing all the pushback
against that in right wing channels like
fox news
we've been speaking about tom hartman's
latest book the hidden history of
neoliberalism how reaganism gutted
america and how to restore its greatness
tom always appreciate your time and your
insights thank you david it's such a
pleasure and an honor to be on your
program i really appreciate you inviting
me thank you
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind-the-scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies mugs and
t-shirts you can support the show for as
little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow all right we may have
gotten some information about this very
strange unexplained trip to washington
dc that donald trump made uh sunday
night yesterday we reported on
some of the speculation that this may be
because trump is getting arrested or
maybe trump is having some kind of
medical appointment in washington dc or
whatnot
the new uh
i don't know that it's necessarily the
consensus but the way things are
pointing is that donald trump flew up to
dc to go to his virginia golf club to
meet with lawyers and aides on the golf
course to avoid the potential
surveillance and media scrutiny that
could take place if such a meeting
actually happened at a lawyer's office
and of course the lawyers that he is
currently meeting with believed to be
believed to be
related to criminal defense that donald
trump may need if indeed he is indicted
so let's go through what we know at this
point business insider reporting trump
spotted at his virginia golf course
after video of him on a flight to the dc
area sparked a firestorm of speculation
now the big
component about this
is that donald trump was on the golf
course and we have a video of it
with no golf clubs
clearly not playing golf and so this was
the start of well what it what is the
point of this what's going on here is
this sort of a mobster-like meeting
where donald trump is getting away
from media and possible surveillance or
whatever else the case may be and you
see trump driving around in a golf cart
he's not golfing there's no golf clubs
whatsoever and a number of people who
know trump by the way just
trump going around in a golf cart
there's something just kind of funny and
absurd about it um
this video was shot at quite a distance
by the way so all sorts of different
speculation and questions as to what
this is about michael cohen friend of
the david pakman show and former trump
lawyer who knows trump very very well
uh has a very good tweet thread about
this where he says many are asking me
why mr mushroom putter was at his dc
golf course which is really in virginia
he says to play golf my sources say he
was meeting with two lawyers in secrecy
and didn't trust being at their offices
notice there are no clubs on the cart no
golf clubs on the cart
glad that drudge found this tweet both
newsworthy and humorous for his readers
to enjoy yeah so that's michael cohen's
perspective and indeed when you look
there are no golf clubs there we then
have a uh hold on there was another one
um which i have no there wasn't that
that is the one so
this seems to basically be the most
logical explanation at this point in
time if donald trump did it media
follows and covers trump to the degree
that they are able to and informed and
know where he's going so we know the
trip to dc
was unannounced that doesn't mean it was
necessarily unplanned it might have been
planned at the last minute and media
were not told about it uh if donald
trump had ended up at walter reed or at
some kind of medical center it would be
known it would have become news and so
this now is the most likely explanation
which is trump uh paranoid trump
surveillance concerned trump or whatever
it is you want to say
wanted to meet with people
outside of the range
of whatever it was that he was paranoid
about and it all is believed to be
related to donald trump's need for
criminal lawyers
as we potentially get closer and closer
to an indictment now let's talk a little
bit about the indictment as is often the
case we saw this with matt gates and
this is ongoing with matt gates
there is a search warrant there is news
of an investigation and then there is no
indictment immediately or whatever and
people start emailing me and asking
questions about well
when is the indictment coming
and when it comes to the trump
indictment
it is completely plausible
that we are still months from such an
indictment if one is coming it takes a
long time to complete this these
investigations and again there's still
an if as to whether trump is going to
get indicted i can only assume based on
the amount of seriousness
and planning
with which the search warrant was
approved on trump fbi approval
attorney general approval uh judge
signature all of the things that must be
done that have to be done when you are
doing something like this with a former
president i can only imagine that it's
going to take more than the few weeks
that remain between now and the midterm
election
for
final decisions to be made about
charging or not charging trump what
would be in that indictment and there is
also a there are some reports that
the charges would not be made before the
election to avoid the appearance of of
polit trying to have political influence
i actually think that it's less likely
that that's the explanation and it's
more likely that it just takes time to
put charges like this together we will
follow it rudy giuliani who was at one
point known as mayor 911 who presided
over the city of new york as its mayor
during and in the immediate aftermath of
the 9 11 attacks
appeared on real america's voice with dr
gina now we'll get to this dr gina thing
in a second why why is she dr gina and
why are what kind of a doctor is she
pay really close attention to this clip
rudy giuliani does not reject 9 11
conspiracies
in this interview when the host floats
listen i'm not that conspiratorial
but i'm starting to wonder about some of
these conspiracy theories about 9 11
myself
and rudy rather than rejecting out of
hand those conspiracy theories which
relate to an event that happened in new
york while he was governor i'm sorry
mayor of new york city
um he sort of says yeah there's lots of
stuff that i didn't believe which turned
out to be true
check this out and pay really close
attention to the language being used
here
and mayor i guess i just i have to ask
you this because it struck me yesterday
as i as i looked through the post you
know you always see
all the posts on social media on
september 11th and and and rightly so we
should absolutely remember and never
forget but i noticed a sincere
strong uptick
and the number of folks asking about
things that have traditionally been
painted conspiracy theories regarding
september 11th and i noticed a lot of
people saying things like uh that is
disrespectful to those who've died and
those who suffered to ask any questions
about it but i also know mayor not only
did you live through 9 11 you've been a
target of the federal government um
you've been one of those people who has
been persecuted one of the 50 or more we
know at this point
persecuted basically for doing your job
and being friends with the president um
so i just so understand the connection
that's being drawn here okay
dr gina says listen
uh
i'm not big on these 9 11 conspiracy
theories but
i'm now starting to be a little more
sympathetic to the 9 11's conspiracy
theory people
because similarly there are people who
said things about you mr mayor that
turned out to be untrue as well
and so if those uh
those things were wrong
maybe the conspiracy theorists about 9
11 are right that's what dr gina is
saying now by the way let's talk and
we're going to continue with the clip dr
gina this is gina louden
she's known as dr gina she's just a
right-wing media personality now you
might remember
when it was dr jill biden all of these
right-wingers were saying that's not a
medical doctor
why are they calling her dr jill biden
that's absolutely crazy she's a doctor
of education
um
dr gina
has a phd
in human and organization systems
from fielding graduate university which
is an online school now there's nothing
wrong with online school or any of it
but
that doctorate
is completely irrelevant to her role as
the host of the dr gina show
just so many people might not even know
this rachel maddow
um was a rhodes scholar
and has a doctorate of philosophy
in politics
from the university of oxford okay
it would still be a bit much to say dr
rachel maddow the dr rachel maddow show
although i would argue that her
d fill in politics from oxford
is more relevant and more impressive
than what makes gina lauden a doctor
but
where were they when it was dr jill
biden's degree shouldn't be mentioned
but yet now it's the dr gina show it's
absurd and you'll actually hear rudy
refer to her as doctor which is just
like the cherry on top i i guess
i kind of was thinking yesterday i i
don't believe the things that i've read
about that but i
i don't fault people anymore for asking
questions that may sound outlandish when
our government is a proven enemy of some
people oh mayor i wanted to give you a
chance to speak to this yeah well you
know uh uh doctor that's really um
[ __ ]
up
why does it feel absurd for him or to
refer to her as doctor in this context i
find myself now
uh
saying things and realizing they're true
that if i had said them five years ago i
would have thought i was crazy right i
mean i would have well we think you're
crazy now for saying them but right
let's take russian collusion
that a political party would spend a
couple million dollars to make up a
charge to frame
a candidate for president
then to try to frame a president
and remove him on a charge that was
purchased and as a complete line
carry it on for four or five years and
have the support of the american press
i would have said that's crazy that
can't happen that can't possibly happen
the press will be outraged they'll go
nuts and once they found out that it was
a complete fraud
they just go on to the next fraud the
whole thing with the ukraine which
turned out to be another fraud and then
they go on to suppress
the uh the hard drive which contains
so basically what rudy is saying is
instead of dr gina
let me be very clear doctor
dr gina did i mention doctor
i was mayor of 9 11 when that happened
and what took place on that day
is that
more than a dozen uh men
mostly saudis
attacked us
and they flew two planes and then
another one crashed in pennsylvania you
know
then the three fine um
he doesn't do that
he instead says hey listen
uh i know what you're saying about maybe
these conspiracy theorists are right
there was the russia thing and then
there was the ukraine thing as he says
it and on and on and on he is not
rejecting the idea that the 911
conspiracy theories may be true he was
mayor of of new york during 9 11
and he now and again i don't actually
think rudy believes any of the
conspiracy theories i think rudy knows
exactly what happened on 9 11 the way
the way we've all gotten to the bottom
of it as donald trump says we have not
but he has been so sucked in by this
just vile right-wing movement
non-thinking movement
that this is the answer that he has to
give it's a sad state of affairs
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p now yesterday during the
show my microphone fell it fell on me
and it actually smacked me in the face
and if you were listening to yesterday's
show you might have heard me say oh i
just lost my microphone and heard a gunk
for lack of a better term
the video of the microphone falling on
me is on my instagram which you can find
at david.pakman
this listener this viewer rather
um called in about how close of a call i
had
with the microphone yesterday listen to
this
hi david you need to go back and
re-watch your show when your microphone
fell because if you had not looked over
to i guess it would have been your left
that i think that thing would have
gotten you right in the eye oh my gosh i
i think you're very lucky that you had
it hit the side of your face and not
your eye oh my gosh i'm glad it did not
get you in the eye
okay well i am one of your avid fans and
a member so i appreciate your show i
enjoy listening to it every day and um
have a nice day well thank you for that
yeah no i did go back and i watched it
slowly sort of like the zapruder film
frame by frame and i did take a little
bit of a hit
uh on the right side of my face from the
microphone falling
had i been looking in a different
direction as the mic fell
it could have gotten me in the eye and i
am not a medical doctor to be very clear
but i think that that would have been
bad i think it might have uh i don't
know that i would be here hosting
necessarily today
had that taken place so if you're
curious what that looked like there is
video of it on my instagram which you
can find at david.pakman we have a great
bonus show for you today we're down to
the final primaries of 2022. we'll tell
you what they are and what to watch and
how things are looking number two
alabama is jailing pregnant cannabis
users to protect quote protect the
fetuses
what yes
and major credit card companies are
making it easier to track gun sales
and the gun people are
furious
all of those stories and more
on today's bonus show oh the bonus show
where you want to make money everybody
else that makes money to find themselves
is bad well we do fund ourselves yes
there is money exchanged with the bonus
show you can sign up at joinpacman.com
you will get instant access to the bonus
show and i look forward to seeing you
then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
real quick go check out jayatal the uk's
most exciting electronic music duo their
newest release connected is available
wherever you get music it's energetic
melodic blast of electronica ingeniously
infused with acoustic instruments and
they support the david pakman show check
them out using the link below